Sind Sie?
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
73 und man sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. April 1952.
1952.
Und wie groß sind Sie zurzeit?
1,78 m.
1,78 m? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
86 kg.
86 kg?
Ja. Herr Bokeman, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Das ist Herr Doktor Müller.
Herr Doktor Müller.
Vielen Dank, Herr Bokeman.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich habe seit gestern ziemlich starke Schmerzen im Bauch.
Okay.
Mehr im oberen Bauch.
Mhm.
Und die strahlen auch in den Rücken aus.
Okay.
Sind diese Beschwerden rechts- oder links- oder links-seitig?
Na, sind mehr so in der Mitte und mehr links.
Mitte und mehr links. Okay.
Ähm, strahlen diese Schmerzen in den ganz Rücken?
Nein, so auf der Höhe, wo ich die Bauchschmerzen habe,
sind die Schmerzen auch hinten im Rücken.
Okay, könnten wir sagen oder beschreiben,
wie Gürtel für mich oder?
Ja, wie kann man sagen Gürtel für mich?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, Herr Bokeman, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben
auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10,
wo 1 und keine Schmerzen bedeutet und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen?
7 bis 8.
7 bis 8, okay.
Und können Sie diese Beschwerden Schmerzen aushalten
oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Noch kann ich sie aushalten.
Wenn es jetzt nicht so lange dauert, kann ich sie aushalten.
Ja, es dauert ungefähr 15, 20 Minuten,
das kann ich aushalten.
Okay, okay, super.
Nehmen Sie dagegen, haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Bis jetzt nicht.
Was versteckt oder verlinnt Ihre Schmerzen, Herr Bokeman?
Also bewegen ist nicht gut.
Ich bleibe lieber liegen auf dem Rücken
und ziehe die Beine etwas an, die Knie stelle ich etwas an.
Das ist noch mit am besten.
Okay.
Das ist genau.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben als brennende Schmerz,
brennend oder dumpf?
Sind mehr dumpf und bohrend.
Ah, okay, dumpf und bohrend.
Haben Sie begleitende Symptome wie Übelkeit erbrechen?
Ja, mir ist übel ziemlich stark
und ich habe bisher auch zweimal erbrochen.
Okay.
Wann war das?
Ja, das eine war vielleicht vor 10 Stunden
oder so und das andere war vor 2 Stunden.
Okay.
Und vor 2 Stunden.
Und wie sah Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Gibt es Bulutung oder?
Schleimig gelblich.
Schleimig und gelblich.
Gibt es keine Bulutung, oder?
Bulut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, okay.
Sind Sie diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal?
Ja, so stark.
Ich hatte vor einem halben Jahr mal auch 2 Tage Bauchschmerzen.
Die waren auch ziemlich stark, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Okay.
Die gingen nicht ähnlich.
Ähnlich.
Aber nicht so stark.
Nicht so stark.
Die gingen nach 2 Tagen aber wieder weg.
Aber jetzt sind Sie deutlich stärker und das macht mir Sorgen.
Okay, ich verstehe, dass das für Sie sehr unangenehm ist.
Ja, Herr Bekremann.
2 Tage haben Sie, hatten Sie diese Schmerzen damals?
Ja.
Und selbst gegangen sind diese Beschwerden?
Wann war das ganz genau?
Da war ich empfehlt.
Ja, das war vor einem halben Jahr.
Das war so im August vielleicht.
Juli, August letzten Jahres.
Okay.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden haben Sie andere Arztbesuche?
Nein, ich war da im Urlaub in Österreich.
Das ging ja nach 2 Tagen wieder besser.
Dann bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Bekremann?
Ja, ich habe Fieber gemessen.
Vorhin hatte ich 38,3.
Ich fühle mich auch so etwas heiß an und ich habe auch starke Schwitzt.
Okay, starke Schwitzt.
Auch seit gestern Abend?
Ja, im Laufe der Nacht.
Letzten Nacht.
Herr Bekremann, normalerweise, wie ernähren Sie sich?
Ich fühle mich ernähre.
Ich esse gerne Fleisch.
Okay.
Meine Frau sagt immer, ich soll mehr Obst und Gemüse essen.
Aber das mag ich nicht so gerne.
Ich esse lieber Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Okay, Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Trinken Sie viel Alkohol oder Kaffee?
Alkohol trinke ich schon regelmäßig.
2-3 Flaschen Bier pro Tag trinke ich.
Und auch mal so Schnäpse, 1-2 Schnäpse.
Ein bis 2 täglich, oder?
Ja.
Und Kaffee?
Morgen trinke ich 2 Tassen Kaffee.
2 Morgens, okay.
Leiten Sie unter Belebungen,
Leitpläns oder Belebungen?
Oder haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Sie ein Hochkommande von Mageninhalt haben?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt bisher.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen
oder enge Gefühle?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Bekremann, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie in Netzteilzeit
in Ihrem Bauch
Vorfüllung
Geschwellung
oder gelbliche Farbeveränderung in Ihrer Körper,
Ganzenkörper?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgespalten.
Gibt es in Ihrer Klankenbereich
oder Umgebung Ihrer Narbefahbeveränderungen
wie Bläuliche oder Brauna?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Herr Bekremann,
werde ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer
Allgemeine Medizinische Situation
zustande stellen.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie seit gestern Abend Fieber haben
und Froschitz schützen.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe in der letzten Nacht
auch stärker geschwitzt.
Sonst schwitze ich nicht nachts.
Okay, normalerweise nicht.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit oder Ihr Gewicht
in letzter Zeit verandert?
Nein, Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Wie gesagt, ich esse gerne Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ich meine nicht gestern,
sondern vorher.
Ich muss zwar in der Nacht 2-mal auf Toilette
Wasser lassen, das aber schon längere Zeit.
Aber ich kann normalerweise wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay, normalerweise gut.
Außer diese Wasserlastenprobleme haben Sie
andere Probleme in Ihrer Urin?
Ich habe nicht viele Brünnandeschmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber seit gestern habe ich keinen Stuhlgang.
Normalerweise regelmäßig jeden Tag.
Haben Sie Ihre Ernährungsgewohnheiten
verändern in den letzten Wochen?
Nein, aber ich habe nicht mehr.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Ach, ich habe nicht mehr.
Nein, immer gleich, oder?
Immer gleich.
Herr Buckermann, leiten Sie unser Husten
Atemnot, Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Atemnot, Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Mein Arzt sagt immer, ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich so lange schon rauche.
Ich muss morgens häufiger so abhusten.
Wenn ich aufgestanden bin, dann habe ich längere Zeit Husten.
Da kommt auch manchmal Schleim raus.
Das ist im Winter schlimmer als im Sommer.
Das habe ich jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit.
Seit wann haben Sie chronische Bronchitis?
Ich würde sagen mindestens schon 5-6 Jahre.
Mindestens 5-6 Jahre.
Wurde bei Ihnen COPD Diagnose?
Ja, ich habe es schon seit 6 Jahren.
Wurde bei Ihnen COPD Diagnose festgestellt?
Wissen Sie?
Ich war einmal bei einem Lungenfacharzt.
Der hat etwas gesagt, der chronische Bronchitis.
Der sagt, das kommt vom Rauchen.
Sie leiten unter keine Herzrasen
oder Herzstolpern?
Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe schon seit 10-15 Jahren.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Stress?
Als Blöder?
Nein, ich habe keinen Stress.
Ich bin in Rente schon seit fast 10 Jahren.
Wenn ich in Rente bin, habe ich keinen Stress.
Prima.
Herr Bockermann, trainieren Sie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich trainiere.
Nein, ich treffe.
Ich gehe zwischendurch etwas spazieren.
Aber das ist nicht weit.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Urlose regelmäßig?
Nein, Urlose nicht.
Da war ich das letzte Mal vor 2 Jahren.
Ich gehe alle 1-2 Mal im Jahr.
Ich gehe zum Hausarzt.
Ich brauche auch meine Medikamente.
Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Genuss mit Herrn Bockermann.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche seit 30 Jahren, 35 Jahren.
Ich rauche eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Haben Sie schon einmal versucht,
mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören?
Nein.
Ich brauche auch eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Also, die Rauchen auch zu hören oder Alkohol?
Nein, viele wollen das.
Meine Kinder wollen das auch immer.
Meine Freunde sagen, auch.
Ich will das nicht.
Ah, ihr wollt das nicht.
Ja, ihr solltet mit dem Rauchen und Alkohol
eigentlich mit dem Rauchen und Alkohol aufzuhören.
Sie wollen das nicht.
würde Ihnen gerne helfen. Ja, aber jetzt habe ich erst mal diese starken Schmerzen. Ja, okay.
Sie haben recht. Okay. Nehmen Sie Drogen? Nein. Nein, absolut. Haben Sie Allergie oder
Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Bokeman? Nein. Nein. Ja, Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie an einem
chronische Bronchitis leiden seit fünf, sechs Jahren und an einem Arterie-Land hier per Tonie
leiden. Seit zehn, 15 Jahren. Richtig. Ja, und ich habe auch noch zwei Gichtanfälle gehabt. Okay.
Diese Harnsäure ist erhöht und da muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen. Okay. Wann war das?
Wann war diese Arterie? Die Gichtanfälle waren so vor drei Jahren und vor vier Jahren, glaube ich.
Vor drei, vor vier Jahren. Gibt es weitere Grundschalkrankungen, Herr Bokeman? Nein. Nein. Nein. Wurden
Sie sich schon einmal operiert? Ja, als Kind wurde ich am Leistenbruch operiert. Da war ich,
glaube ich, elf Jahre alt auf der rechten Seite. Mit den Rechtenbruch? Ja, rechts. Und dann
hatte ich nochmal eine Operation, da habe ich meinen linker Unterarm gebrochen. Da war ich so,
wie alt war ich da vielleicht? Da habe ich Sport gemacht, da habe ich Fußball gespielt. Da war
ich vielleicht 19, 20 und da war der Unterarm gebrochen, der musste operiert werden. 19, 20,
ungefähr Jahre alt. Gibt es weitere Operationen? Nein. Okay. Waren diese Operationen komplikationslos?
Ja, so weit ich weiß, ja. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein, Herr Bokeman?
Also ich nehme einmal für die Harnsäure, diese Harnsäureerhöhung, da nehme ich ein Mittel ein,
Moment, das heißt, alopurinol. Alopurinol, wie viel Milligramm und wie oft nehmen Sie
regelmäßig ein? Also, da vernehm ich eine am Tag und dahinter steht 300. 300 Milligramm. Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch eine, die eine Tablette habe ich, die habe ich nicht vertragen, da habe
ich stärkeren Husten vorgekriegt für den Blutdruck, die wurde gestellt und jetzt nehme ich seit ungefähr
zwei Jahren das Mittel heißt Candesatan, da ist der Husten nicht stärker geworden mit der Tablette.
Candesatan, acht, steht dahinter, da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends. Eine abends. Alles klar.
Und gibt es weitere Medikamente? Nein. Zum Beispiel für die hrunche Branche. Nein, da nehme ich nichts.
Da wurde diskutiert, ob ich da so ein Sprehen nehmen soll und aber ich habe irgendwas gegen
Medikamente und da hat der Hausarzt gesagt, dann wollen wir erst mal gar nichts machen, weil er glaubt,
ich bin da nicht so zuverlässig. Okay. Herr Bockermann, gibt es in ihrer Familie
gruntsche Erkrankungen? Ja, mein Vater, der ist verstorben an Lungenkrebs. Er ist mir sehr leid.
Er war ja, wie alt war er, da 86? 86, ja, er war alt, ja und er hatte auch hohen Blutdruck. Und die
Mutter, die ist verstorben im Alter von 85, sie hatte einen Sturz im Haus, ist die Treppe
runtergestürzt und hatte ein Blutung im Kopf, im Gehirn und sie hatte da auch einen Oberschenkelbruch.
Und an den Folgen ist sie dann verstorben. Mein herzlicher und beileiter Herr Bockermann.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, er ist 70 Jahre alt, der wurde vor zwei Jahren am Darmkrebs operiert.
Wie ist ihr gesund? Du geht es eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Ja, okay, das freut mich. Sie sind Rentner und was waren Sie von Beruf für Rüder?
Ich war vom Beruf Elektriker.
Elektriker, leben Sie allein Herr Bockermann?
Ja, inzwischen, ich bin seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, 15 Jahren, ne, zwölf Jahren von meiner Frau geschieden.
Zwölf Jahren, okay. Und leben Sie allein? Ja.
Seitdem oder? Sind Sie pro ständig geimpft?
Ja, wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe, dann macht er gerade im Herbst immer eine Impfung gegen Grippe und gegen Corona.
Das habe ich jetzt im November bekommen.
Aber ansonsten schaut er immer so, was so notwendig ist.
Okay, und haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Ja, aber nicht so wesentlich. Ich war mal in Österreich und mal an der Ostsee.
Aber sonst keine weiteren Reisen, keine Fernreisen.
Okay, wann war diese Reisungen?
Österreich war ich vor einem halben Jahr.
Im August, als ich diese Bauchschmerzen hatte, für zwei Tage.
Ah, ja, ja, genau.
Da war ich in Österreich und im Oktober war ich noch mal eine Woche an der Ostsee.
Wo war Ostsee?
Ja, Herr Bockermann, jetzt möchte ich kurz zusammenpassen.
Wenn ich etwas falsch sage, könnt ihr mich bitte korrigieren.
Seit gestern Abend oder Morgen?
Seit gestern Morgen.
Haben Sie starke Bauchschmerzen im Oberanbau?
Aber mittiger und linksseitig.
Mitte und links, ja.
Sie beschreiben Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala mit sieben bis acht Konzenen.
Und Ihre Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken.
In den Rücken, ja.
Rücken aus.
Bei Bewegung verschlimmen sich die Schmerzen.
Und Sie beschreiben auch diese Schmerzen als dumpf und bohrend.
Außerdem haben Sie seit gestern Überkeit und haben sie zweimal erbrochen.
Einmal vor ungefähr zehn Stunden, einmal vor zwei Stunden.
Und diese Erbrochene sah schleimig und gärtlich aus.
Richtig resten, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Normalerweise gehen Sie zur Zolletze regelmäßig für den Stuhl.
Aber seit gestern haben Sie keinen Stuhl.
Ja.
Okay.
Möchtern Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen an mich?
Nein, Hauptsache mir wird bald geholfen.
Ja, ich werde gerne Ihnen helfen, Herr Bochermann.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, Ihre Vizapparameter messen und Blut abnehmen.
Danach brauchen wir einige operativ diagnostische Methoden, um die genaue Diagnose stellen zu können.
Wenn wir alle Ergebnisse zusammengetragen haben, werden wir miteinander noch einmal sprechen.
Okay.
Das können wir so machen.
Ich komme gleich zur Untersuchung.
Alles klar.
Danke.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, umzuschreiben, die Patientensprache in Fachbegriffe.
Okay.
Die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die heute Abend hier dabei sind, haben vielleicht noch Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Herr Bochermann, gibt es irgendwelche Ausstöße für diese Schmessen?
Im Spiel haben Sie vielleicht vorgestern viel Alkohol getrunken oder nach dem Fatigue es speisen?
Ja.
Vorgestern war ich beim Nachbarn, der hatte Geburtstag, da habe ich vielleicht ein, zwei Schnäppze mehr getrunken.
Das kann sein.
Danke schön.
Der Schmerz ist immer da.
Manchmal wird er etwas schlimmer.
Manchmal kommt so eine Welle.
Aber das ist nicht sehr oft.
Aber der Schmerz ist immer da, nie weg.
Würde bei Ihnen Magandam-Spiegelung irgendwann durchgeführt?
Nein.
Danke schön.
Die Schmerzen hatte ich ja vor einem halben Jahr mal, da waren sie aber nicht so stark.
Das dauerte nur zwei Tage.
Das war im Urlaub in Österreich und danach bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Aber eine Magandam-Spiegelung wurde noch nie gemacht.
Danke schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo.
Soll ich?
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patentin aufgenommen.
Ich habe sehr kurz Zeit dafür.
Ja.
Es handelt sich um Paul Bochermann.
Er ist eine 73-Jährige.
Er stellte sich heute seit gestern Morgen bestehender.
Abdominalgie bei uns vor.
Er beschrieb die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala mit 7 bis 8 von 10.
Er war sehr dumm und bohrend.
Bis jetzt hat er keine, oder seine Hausarzt oder andere Arzt nicht besucht.
Er ist zum ersten Mal zu uns gekommen.
Er ist zu uns gekommen.
Er hat seine Schmerzen strahlen in den Rücken.
Wie gut er für mich.
Die Abdominalgie stehen besonders in der Mitte und mehr links.
Im gesamten Bauch oder mehr im Unter- oder Oberbauch?
Oberbauch.
Er hat gesagt, ja.
Ich habe das kurz zusammen.
Der 73-Jährige Patient, Herr Bochermann, berichtet über starke Abdominalschmerzen.
Überwiegend im Epigastrium links mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal.
Genau.
Ich bitte nicht in den Rücken sagen möglichst nach Dorsal.
Der Schmerz wird als dumm und bohrend beschrieben.
Auf der Schmerzskala zwischen 7 und 8.
Er hat dagegen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Bei Bewegung hat er diese Schmerzen schlechter gefühlt.
Wenn er seine Knie beugen, hat er sich besser beschwerten.
Das ist besser geworden.
Diese Schmerzen verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung.
Bei Rückenlage mit angewinkelten Knien.
Angewinkelten Knien.
Er hat diese Schmerzen schon mal gehabt.
Vor einem halben Jahr, als er nach Österreich gegangen ist,
hat er zwei Tage solche Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark.
Diese Beschwerden sind selbst gegangen.
Deswegen hat er keinen Arzt besucht.
Er wollte zuerst sagen, dass er aus dem Ausseher uns Ermesis hat.
Und seit gestern hat er zweimal erbrochen.
Einmal war es vor 10 Stunden.
Und einmal war es vor zwei Stunden und seine Erbrochene sah schleimig und gelblich aus.
Okay, gut.
Ja, außerdem hat sie seit gestern Abend Fibrikes gefühlt und er hat einmal gemessen.
Er war der Kompassimperatur, 38,3 Grad.
Außer dem hatte er Schütterfrost und nächtliche Hyperhydrosa.
Okay.
Ich habe gefragt, wie er sich ernährt.
Und er ernährt sich normalerweise viel Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Außer dem trinkt er viel Bier und Schnepze.
Zwei bis drei Flasche biatäglich und auch Schnepze zwei bis zwei Mal.
Ein bis zwei Mal.
Ich schuldigung.
Wir können dazu sagen, sagen Sie ruhig dazu, es besteht ein erheblicher, ein erheblicher
Alkoholkonsum.
Erheblicher.
Erheblicher, heißt ja, also schon deutlich erhöht.
Okay.
Erheblicher Alkoholkonsum von zwei bis drei Flaschen Bier pro Tag und zwei bis drei Schnepsen
pro Tag.
Okay.
Das ist schon ein erhebliches Maß zu viel Alkohol.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Vielen Dank.
Vorgestern ist er eine Einladung gegangen und er hat viel getrunken als vorher.
Ja, eins bis zwei Schnepen, Schnepsen.
Schnepse, ja.
Mehr, mehr Schnepsen.
Genau.
Vorzunehmen, noch zu den allgemeinen Zeichen.
Hat der Patient Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen und beim Stuhlgang?
Ja.
Der Wasserlassen hat er normalerweise täglich zweimal Wasserlassen, besonders in der Nacht.
Aber kennen Sie da den Fachbegriff für nächtliches Wasserlassen?
Genau, Necturie.
Ja, Necturie.
Und normalerweise sein Stuhl gewohnheit ist sehr regelmäßig, aber seit gestern hat er
keinen Stuhl mehr.
Der Patient hat normalerweise täglich Stuhlgang, täglich.
Täglich Stuhlgang.
Täglich Stuhlgang, aber seit gestern nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr, seit gestern nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ihr Appetit oder Gewicht hat sich in letzter Zeit nicht verwendet.
Er leidet an einem chronische Bronchitis seit fünf bis sechs Monaten.
Deswegen hat er im Winter schlimmer geworden.
Er ist sehr husten-schlimmer geworden.
Man kann sagen, er hat morgens einen produktiven Husten.
Produktiven Husten.
Also mit Expektoranz.
Genau.
Und er rauft regelmäßig Einschärfte pro Tag seit fünf und 30 Jahren.
Und Drogenkonsum wurden verneins.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht ein Nikotin ab Usus von 35 Packageiers.
Packageiers.
Eine Packung pro Tag, 35 Jahre kann man sagen 35 Jahre.
Genau, das ist einfach.
Packageiers.
Bei ihm ist keine Allergie oder unsere Verträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er leidet außerdem an einer arteriellen Hypertonis seit zehn bis 15 Jahren.
Er hatte zwei Mal Arctitis urica vor drei Jahren und vier Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er regelmäßig täglich 300 mg Aluptoinol und er leidet an ein arteriellen
Hypertonis.
Und deswegen hat er seit zwei Jahren regelmäßig kann der Sartan 8 mg morgens und abends ein.
Okay.
Bei ihm wurde mit 11 Jahren eine Operation durchgeführt in Guinalhaini.
Ja, in Guinalhaini Operation im rechten Seid durchgeführt und wegen einer Fraktur, welche
Fraktur, unser Arm Fraktur, Radius oder Urla, in Linkenarm eine Operation durchgeführt
im Jahr von 19 oder 20.
Ja, im Alter.
Im Alter von 19.
Im Alter von genau.
Okay, das waren die Operationen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, und gibt es Erkrankungen in der Familie?
Ja, seine beide Eltern sind verstorben.
Seine Vater hat einen lungen Bruchatkarzinom erlitten und mit 68 Jahren ist er verstorben.
Seine Mutter war 85 Jahre und er hatte einen Unfall.
Zu Hause ist sie gestürzt oder gestürzt.
Eine Treppe hinunter gestürzt, ja.
Und die Gehirnblutung hatte sie damals?
Der Patient hat gesagt, sie hatte eine Gehirnblutung.
Sie können sagen Schädelhirntrauma.
Schädelhirntrauma.
Sie sagen, sie mutter erlitt ein Schädelhirntrauma.
Und was noch?
Noch eine Fraktur hatte sie.
Daran ist die Mutter verstorben.
Genau.
An diesem Unfallfolgen ist die Mutter verstorben.
Okay, gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er hat ein Bruder.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt, vor zwei Jahren.
Er hat einen Kolonkarzinom erlitten und er wurde operiert.
Er ist jetzt gut.
Es geht ihm ganz gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die Beschwerden sprechen für eine Pankreatitis.
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen,
eine akute Holistitis und Gastroenteritis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten zunächst körperlich untersuchen.
Natürlich, zum nächsten Italparametamessen,
Blut abnehmen, EKG schreiben,
um mögliche Herzerkrankungen auszuschließen.
Danach werde ich ihn körperlich untersuchen.
Im Blut werde ich amylase,
oder Cross-Bluet-Bilds,
CRP, BSG-Werte, Troponin, TK, TK, MB,
amylase, amylase, Lipase,
biliribin, alle PLP,
AST, GGT-Werte.
Gut, das beherrschen Sie perfekt.
Vielen Dank, das können Sie.
Die Verdachtdiagnose kann ich teilen.
Eventuell ist es ja so,
dass es schon der zweite Schub einer Pankreatitis ist.
Vor einem halben Jahr hatte der Patient auch
ähnliche epigastrische und dorsale Schmerzen,
nicht ganz so stark.
Man kann eventuell davon ausgehen,
dass er da schon mal einen Pankreatitis-Schub hatte.
Jetzt ist es schlimmer, heftiger, stärker.
Es spricht einiges dafür.
Der Patient hat einen erheblichen Alkoholkonsum.
Vor zwei Tagen hatte er
wahrscheinlich noch mehr Schnaps getrunken bei der Eier.
Das spricht alles ein bisschen dafür.
Die Differenzialdiagose kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Man muss eventuell reflektorisch denken,
dass er vielleicht einen Subelius hat.
Kein Stuhlgang seit gestern.
Das ist oft reflektorisch der Elius,
aufgrund der Abdominatschmerzen.
Aber auch das muss sicherlich gut abgeklärt werden,
nicht, dass der Patient auch noch einen Elius entwickelt.
Zu der Pankreatitis.
Aber ich denke, Sie haben das ja gut gemacht.
Worauf Sie achten müssen.
Sie haben vielleicht den Gong gehört.
Nach 20 Minuten kam eine Musik.
Sie waren am Ende bei 24 Minuten für die Anamnese.
Ich glaube, Sie haben in der Prüfung 20 Minuten Zeit.
So wird mir das zumindest berichtet.
Da achten Sie bitte ein bisschen drauf,
dass Sie in dem Zeitrahmen bleiben.
Das ist eine sehr gute Prüfung.
Sie haben den Gong gehört.
Sie haben die Prüfung,
dass Sie in dem Zeitrahmen bleiben.
Sonst kann es passieren,
dass vielleicht dann gesagt wird, so ist 20 Minuten.
Jetzt können Sie nicht weiterfragen.
Jetzt ist die Anamnese zu Ende,
dass Sie versuchen, die Zeit gut einzuhalten.
Das Zeitmanagement zu optimieren.
Ich habe Sie sprachlich sehr gut verstanden.
Sie haben auch, denke ich, gute Fragen gestellt.
Sie haben die Prüfung etwas mehr Zeit.
Sie lassen sich die Begriffe wie nächtliches Wasser lassen.
Sie markieren das gleich.
Sie können die Leistenhernie noch sagen.
Im Alter von 11 Jahren erfolgte eine Herneotomie.
Herneotomie, genau.
Wegen Leistenhernie rechts.
Oder Inguinalhernie rechts.
Das wäre dann perfekt.
Sie haben das gut eingesetzt.
Ich sehe Ihre Prüfung übermorgen.
Können Sie so gelassen entgegensehen, wie es geht?
Es ist immer Stress.
Aber Sie sind gut vorbereitet.
Die anderen Kollegen, die letzte Woche zugehört haben,
ich zeige Ihnen meine Haut.
Sie haben die Prüfung,
die Sie haben,
die Sie haben, die Sie haben, die Sie haben.
Ich zeige Ihnen meine Haut.
Ich habe seit 10 Tagen keine Therapie gemacht.
Die Krusten sind fast alle abgefallen.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen Rötungen.
Aber am nächsten Montag muss ich wieder
einen Therapiezögel machen.
Nur so zum Anschauungsunterricht.
Könnten Sie mitteilen,
dass die Medikamente genau namentiert?
Das Medikament heißt ZY.
ZY.
C L A R A ZY.
Das sind feine kleine Päckchen.
Die enthalten wenig Creme.
Die muss ich immer mit einem Finger auftragen.
Der Wirkstoff ist IMI QEMOT.
IMI QEMOT.
Das ist ein Immunstimulanz.
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte Ihnen mitteilen,
dass unser Freikollege
gestern
Ihrer Püfung bestanden haben.
Sehr gut.
Wir stellen Sie den Kollegen meine Glückwünsche.
Wir sind alle sehr denkbar,
dankbar für Ihre Unterstützung.
Ihre Simulation ist sehr hilfreich für uns.
Vielen Dank, Ihre Mühle.
Alles klar.
Wir können gerne weiter machen.
Wir werden uns nächsten Sonnersdach wieder treffen.
Frau Kollegin, ich wünsche Ihnen für die Prüfung alles Gute.
Vielen Dank.
Das werden Sie gut hinkriegen in Stuttgart.